There's any,
there's another strange element to that,
which is that on the one hand,
the,
the radical feminist types that
neo Marxists postmodernists are,
are very much opposed to the patriarchy,
let's say.
And that's that unit,
dimensional,
ideological represented,
average listed every prayer,
perhaps the word can be applied
to Republican Rome and that's it.
Okay.
Well,
and it maybe it could be applied
usefully to certain kinds of tyranny,
but not to a society
that's actually functional.
Victorian England and one arguably.
Okay.
But other than that,
and to use the word patriarchy in that
and that slapdash way fulfill amateur
tourists.
Absolutely.
You know,
just shows people know
nothing about history,
whatever have you had written,
had done no reading.
So,
and so what confuses me about that is
that despite the fact that the Patriarchy
is viewed as this essentially evil entity
and that that's associated with the
masculine energy that built
this oppressive structure,
the antithesis of that,
which would actually be
femininity as far as I can tell,
which is tightly associated with care and
with child rearing is also denigrated.
So it's like the only proper role for
women to adopt is a patriarchal role,
despite the fact that the patriarchy
is something that's entirely corrupt.
So the hypothesis seems to be that the
patriarchy would be just fine if women
ran it.
So no changes.
It's just that would just
be a transformation of
leadership and somehow that
would,
that would rectify the
fundamental problem,
even though it's hypothetically
supposed to be structural.